[Music]
thank you
now let's turn to Westminster where
Rishi sunak has marked his first 100
days as prime minister I am joined by
the great Katie Bulls our politics
editor uh Katie it's been
I mean I would think even the most
Ardent Rishi Defender would say it
hasn't been a glorious first hundred
days for this prime minister is that
fair you think so yeah and we don't have
the most Ardent Rishi Defender here
um but I think if we I think and I think
what's interesting is lots of people
have there's been a narrative recently
which is honeymoon is over I would argue
he maybe never had a honeymoon yes um in
a sense he did come in uh you know Ahmed
Mark at turmoil quickly had to do uh
Autumn statement which the party really
disliked even if it did accept or you
know that mix of tax Rises spending cuts
and so it hasn't really had a had a feel
of a new leader particularly and I think
you can see that in his approval ratings
and as for his first 100 days and what's
happened I think that it has been
difficult for Rishi sunak his uh I
remember when he first came in there was
an argument which is but the Tory
party's ratings are very low but
Richardson is a much higher than the
Tory parties so can he lift the Tory
parties up with his ratings or will he
sing with his parties now he has not
gone all the way to where the Tory party
is but his poll ratings are definitely
um declining quite fast and I think
that's the sort of meeting in the middle
yeah exactly
um well I don't I think that's probably
kind in the sense I don't think the Tory
um rating is particularly gone up yeah
and you know there's he hasn't proved
things slightly from where Liz trust was
uh but you know there's still a pretty
consistent 20-point lead and and this
does have an effect on morale because I
don't there are some MPS who thought
would be more of a bans than Russia
student that came in but also I think um
if if it was almost you know probably
more realistic scenario every week
perhaps the Tories gained a point or
every even a couple of weeks that would
add to probably a sense that this is a a
project which you know you keep going
the Tories will have good results
whereas that's not really happened and
there's lots of reason to see why you
can look at the state of the economy
cost of living uh you know the recent
Tory Rouse on sleeves and there's lots
of factors of making it hard for
everybody to do but it does just mean as
he marks 100 days I think the mood and
the Tory party is pretty low and there's
a difference between low and being
um was wrote you know uh regicide or I
don't I don't think it's in that place
but I think there's just a sense of are
we really going to be able to turn
things around are they because among the
public uh I think there's a sense of
perhaps a Little Bit of Sympathy because
he's obviously uh got a very very
difficult job on any number of fronts
however that is marred by uh the fact
that he was he was Chancellor for a long
time and he's very much associated with
this government that a lot of people
blame for uh the various crises in
Britain at the moment do MPS feel that
too do MPS think uh he needs more time
he and do they have sympathy for him or
do they like the public critical MPS
feel that he's been taught by his
association with the Johnson era so I
think it's a combination I mean I think
I think there is some sympathy for Rishi
Cena within the party which is just it's
a really difficult job he's inherited
and as you say he's not completely
removed from it he was you know the
second most senior figure in government
for a lot of that period and but
therefore I think there's some oh he
needs to be time to to get on with it
but then you also do have plenty of MPS
who um you know increasingly you'll hear
he's too managerial and I wonder if
actually there's uh sometimes I think
there's greater sympathy with some
voters towards racing within the party
and because there are groups that say
well he needs to be more radical and
there's also plenty of MPS who would
rather Boris Johnson had remained as
leader and that's different than saying
we want Boris Johnson back now but think
it was a mistake to ask Boris Johnson in
the first place and those people who
supported Liz truss who think that um
her Legacy ultimately I mean some people
argue there's not a legacy but they
think what she was arguing for in terms
of growth has now just been completely
ignored by Rishi Cena and Jeremy Hunt
and therefore they worry that you know
there's there's a sense I think of
fatalism it's like you're taking over
the Tory party Liz trust is back in the
people today uh some MPS urging her not
to be a destructive force uh now that
she's sort of re-emerging into the
Limelight uh but at the same time as you
suggested the the trust sites uh think
that they were right all along they just
got everything badly wrong at the time
but the message that productivity uh and
lower taxes uh was crucial to the Tories
chances of winning again was was
essentially correct is that not right
yeah I think it's interesting for she
seen it because he is for their free
former prime ministers in the House of
Commons um and I think two years ago
it's just Theresa May now you have Liz
truss and Boris Johnson they pose
different problems for Richard Cena
Boris Johnson is definitely of the he
may come back and try and be prime
minister again and everything is in that
sense no one even lives to us as most
Ardent supporters are saying that she
should come back and be prime minister
or even leader of the opposition of the
Tories lose but she is a problem for
Richie sunette in a sense as you point
to
um her ideology and the school of
thought in the Tory party which she
represented and lots of people say she
is not the right Communicator person to
front it but it's still pretty popular
um and I think therefore Rishi sunak and
I think particularly with the spring
budget I wouldn't expect huge tax cuts
at all but I think that while Richard
said you know growth is one of my five
priorities not so many say well you can
say that but what is your plan for
growth it's not very ambitious so in a
way I think this group were actually
easier for a student to get on side in
some of the Boris Johnson hardcore
supporters because it's less about the
personality it's more about the policies
and but the problem is I think lots of
the trust sites as we may call them feel
as though
um that is just not at all even
entertain the idea of looking at some of
the things this trust suggested and it's
all just seen as completely toxic and
therefore they feel a bit I suppose
patronized and some would say well if
your Premiership ends like that you
shouldn't be heard but there are lots of
MPS you don't think low taxes and supply
side reform should go because of a short
Premiership and finally Katie your
column this week brilliant column you
say 19 the big question among Tory MPS
is is it 1992 or is it 1997 and am I
right and thinking sort of Team uh Rishi
team sunac think that it's 1992 and uh
the people who are in despair think it's
1997. explained a little bit yeah I
think it's a bit of a proxy so basically
if you want to be nice about Richie
sunac um you say it's 1992 and if you
want to be nasty about Richard cement
you say it's going to be 97.
um get ready for this huge Landslide and
actually I think if you speak to MPS
probably with
um an agenda on nyla's side I think
probably what MPS are more likely
thinking is where the party could end up
and obviously we're a long way away is
it's actually a graceful defeat so
somewhere between the two and you hear
Tori MPS talk about how
um if labor just get a small majority
which they think is a decent chance if
you just look at the what is the need
for the large majority the fact you
would expect the poles to tie to near an
election we'll see if it happens this
time around
um you know some MPS will even say it's
preferable right now not for a Wipeout
but you know save labor what a majority
of 20. they think that would give the
party time to regroup
um and uh labor would really struggle
with that and then they would get back
in quite quickly now that could be very
wishful thinking but it's interesting I
think that away from the 92-97 she
cannot avoid at any event really
um I think in private is much more what
counts as a good defeat um for the Tory
party yeah it's probably just all about
the economy really fundamentally isn't
it yeah thank you very much Casey
[Music]